mi salón y el del sinn fein diez mil 845
votos
sonriendo triunfalmente en medio de sus
partidarios
michel o'neal líder del sinn fein
conserva su escaño en la asamblea local
de stormont
90 diputados fueron renovados en estas
elecciones cruciales para el país y por
primera vez en 100 años el poder podría
pasar a manos del sinn fein antiguo
apoyo del rebelde grupo republicano
irlandés durante la guerra civil los
últimos resultados parciales acreditan
al partido por delante de los pro
británicos del dup esto sería un
terremoto político el partido
nacionalista está a favor de la
reunificación con la república y se
plantea un referéndum mientras que los
unionistas se oponen lo he fijado una
fecha pero si quiero que ocurra
llevará a la inestabilidad de irlanda
del norte no resolverá los problemas que
importan a la gente de a pie
desde el break sheet muchos
norirlandeses se lo están pensando
sobre todo porque el 56 se opone a salir
de la unión europea por lo que ahora la
población se siente atraída por la línea
social y de izquierdas de este partido
histórico